how do you start a cosmetics company I
got a question from a reader wrote in
saying I love the videos what steps
should I take to start my own cosmetics
line I have no clue where to start
please help me I'm very ignorant when it
comes to this sincerely feed me juice so
that's a great name so feed me juice I'm
gonna give you juice this video is juice
for you hey Congrats we want to start a
business to get a going from the basics
okay we're gonna go step by step but how
to get this cosmetics line of yours up
and running and successful step 1
you have to figure out what it is that
you love doing what you're passionate
about
and how that applies to your cosmetics
line so I pick one thing that you think
is wrong with the cosmetics industry
right now one thing I don't know much
about Cosmetics not an exit by any
stretch I don't use cosmetics but pick
one thing lipstick eyeliner lashes
foundation whatever it is pick one thing
that you think is wrong then you feel
passionate about the way things are
going right now is wrong and I can fix
it that's where you have to start you
have to start with an idea something you
believe in passionately not just trying
to make a lot of money okay number one
number two start talking to people see
are you the only crazy one or do other
people believe in this as well do other
people think yeah if you made that I buy
it if you created a new line of eyeliner
that didn't smudge they would want that
so you test it I'm not spending any
money yet I'm just going on talking to
people talking about tential customers
and seem to be willing to buy step
number three create your own prototype
okay so hopefully there's something you
could do yourself because I don't want
you spending a lot of money on this
invest your time but don't spend a lot
of money because too many entrepreneurs
go out bring on a loan to start this
company and they're in debt for the rest
of their lives paying this thing off so
find a way to do it yourself and if you
need to recruit people to help you
companies to help whatever it is keep
this thing as low
budget as possible to build your
prototype product then go out and start
selling it talk to all those people who
said they would love it and see if they
will be willing to buy your prototype
now you're not gonna be making tons of
money here because it's taking you a ton
of time to make each individual product
but you're seeing if people react to it
and if it works and people like it and
they'll come back for more if they do if
they love it then you're on to something
if not you have to keep working on it
tinkering until you get the final
product and then the last step is you
start marketing if you know it's working
if you figured out those steps 1 2 4
that's the hardest part you get a
working product that people love and
it's working it's having an impact it's
the benefit that you said you know as
eyeliner it doesn't smudge then you're
ready to expand you can invest more
dollars into it you can grow your
business a slightly alternative path of
this is I hate starting product based
businesses at the beginning because
they're capital intensive it means you
have to put a lot of money into it
so you want to try to start as low
budget as possible but another way to do
it is to think about starting a service
so I don't know what line of business
you're in right now but instead of
starting with your own cosmetics line
start a service what could you do could
you be a beauty consultant could you be
a makeup artist could you be something
that's related to your business so
you're hanging around your customers on
a regular basis and it does a lot of
things for you first it gives you an
income stream it gives you money right
you gotta have money coming in money is
the lifeline of a business you get have
a great idea but if you don't have any
cash coming in you're not gonna be
hugely successful so gives you stable
money coming in a service business is
hard to ramp up and scale but if you're
small and you're starting up it's an
easy way to get money and make sure you
survive number two is you start talking
to your customers it builds a
relationship with them right if they're
hiring you back every week every month
whatever it is you're building a
relationship with them so that when
you're ready to launch your product you
have a ready market these
they trust you they know you they like
you they've been involved in helping
make this thing you've asked for their
feedback all along so when you're
launching they're ready to pay you for
it gives you a greater chance of success
because it gives you cash flow and it
ties you to your customers more tightly
than if you're just going out talking to
people about a product so there's two
paths for you the first of those five
steps launch a product company the
second one will take longer by creating
the service but will give you a greater
chance of being successful in the long
run so good luck you got a challenging
and fun road ahead believe for those of
you watching like the video please give
it a thumbs up below makes you want to
do more for you and I want to hear you
have to think please leave a comment
underneath every morning when I wake up
and I eat my lentils for breakfast I
check out the comments and you guys make
my day start me off on the right path so
please leave a comment and if you have a
question for your own business you can
leave in the comment section below I
always read those I love seeing them
thank you guys I'll see you soon